each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
hi I'm psychotic or I'm a researcher at
max of research India I work in the area
of privacy and online advertising and
today i will talk about this problem
that we've been working on where we
believe we can significantly improve
people's privacy while at the same time
reducing the number of ads number of
irrelevant ads that people see
especially on their phones so how does
advertising work today every time you
use your phone your phone sends a little
bit of information about who you are
what you are doing where you are to some
third party in the cloud and they use
this information to pick ads that might
be of interest to you and they send this
information to your phone now this comes
at a significant loss of privacy for the
user because information about you about
the user is being sent off to who knows
where in the cloud you don't have any
control over it you don't know what
information is being sent you don't know
what they're going to do with it and
this is a huge privacy breach and so we
went and asked advertisers hey why don't
you show ads targeted ads without taking
stealing all this information from the
user's device and they said it cannot be
done it's impossible and so that was the
problem that intrigued us we said no it
should be possible to have a win-win
where the advertisers win by showing
targeted ads and users win by not having
to leak their privacy I mean after all
ads are good because this they provide
us all the free websites and all the
free apps that's how they they make a
living and so this was a challenging
problem that that we set out to solve
having sorted the solution actually ends
up being very very simple and it's
surprising that no one low on thought of
it earlier the idea is instead of you
sending all your information to someone
else and then then picking the best ad
to send back to you why don't they just
send you a bunch of ads to your phone
and your phone which already has
information about you picks the best ad
to show to you so you the user does not
see any more as just that the data that
is used to pick the ads is all local to
your phone it never leaves your phone
and so that was the idea that we said
hey this might work the question of
course becomes is it possible to send
all these as to the phone does it slow
things down does it use up any more
battery and the answer surprisingly to
us was
no it actually ends up saving battery
for the user it ends up saving Internet
bandwidth and it ends up saving time and
the reason is that instead of waiting on
this slow process of sending something
to the cloud and getting the result back
you already have all the information you
need on the phone to pick the best ad
and so what we found surprisingly was
that as a result of this system the ads
that you see are far more relevant and
advertisers want that because relevant
ads is where the user is engaged the
user clicks on it user event buys the
product and because these ads are more
relevant users need to see fewer ads
because the advertisers are still making
just as much money if not more money
from from these ads and finally it
preserves the users privacy and it still
allows us to have all these free
websites and apps that we have and so we
built the system as an experiment and we
piloted it with about 2,000 users and we
showed that this thing that people had
considered impossible in the past is
actually solvable in a win-win way where
the users get better privacy and the
advertisers get better bang for their
buck and the users still don't see too
many ads they see fewer ads and more
relevant ads the project I mentioned is
but one of the projects that we are
working on at max of research in India
we are working in tens of different
areas where every in every area we pick
projects that were previously considered
impossible and we think really hard and
we build solutions that work in the real
world so if we are interested in solving
challenging problems and working with
world-class researchers I encourage you
to contact us through our website
each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you